NEW YORK RANGERS.
SHOULD BE A FUN ONE.
>> Jeff: JACKETS WEA QUICKLY PL
HERE TO START THE SHOW.
THE DOWN AND
DEFENSIVE ZONE, IT'S HARD TO NO
THE ONCOMING RANGER AND THE
JACKETS WILL CHANGE UP. THE BLU
PAINT, YOU SEE GUS NYQUIST
COMING IN WITH AUTHORITY.
AN KELLY
SUTHERLAND REFEREE PUT HIS ARM
AROUND HIM HAD A
THAT'S HIS 17TH OF THE SEASON.
BOARDS LOOKS FOR L THIS TIME
ROBINSON NEUTR AND KREIDER WAS
DENIED BY THE PAD KORPISALO. SA.
LONG SHOT, SAVE KORPISALO, LEFT
OF THE BLUE PAINT.
ROLLING PUCK, REAVES TRYING TO
FEED
JUST ROLLS OFF THE STICK OF
DOMI.
NOWD AWAY.
RECOVERED, NYQUIST, AND NOW
BAYREUTHER WITH A SHOT..D OF
THE NIGHT.
IS DOING IT,
YOUR JOB I THE NEW YORK RANGERS.
>> Jeff: KREIDER SENDS I EXCEPT
AND REAVES JUST SAID OKAY, GOOD
LETS IT GO TO ZIBANEJAD WHO
GAUTHIER, LAFRENIERE, JENNER
JACKETS PUNCH IT OUT OF THE ZONE
AND A RACE ON  SKATE OF TROUBA,
LOOKING FOR GOODROW KNOCKS IT
OUTN THE SLOT,
NYQUIST.
GUS NYQUIST IT IN
FRONT, HAS IT.
LINDGREN RIGHT POINT GOALTENDERD
NOT SEEING PUCKST AND THE
COLUMBUS BLUE JACKETS TAKE AWAY
THE EXTERIOR AND THEN THE
INTERIOR OF THE
ZACH WERENSKII